[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez a más de un cómico
del estudio esta mañana del jueves que
nos vamos a dedicar rosa esta revista de
prensa analizar el día del news report
el informe anual de el roiter se
instituye con la universidad de oxford
que aborda las tendencias en el consumo
de las noticias
buenos días raúl exactamente y sólo lo
podremos repasar por encima y comentar
algunas de las claves porque es muy
extenso particularmente este estudio
está basado en pues en a la el análisis
del comportamiento de 93 mil usuarios
pertenecientes a 46 mercados que según
pues relata el rogers institute
acaparan la mitad de la población
mundial alguna de las claves para
introducirnos en este estudio y es que
en el mundo hispanohablante en argentina
por ejemplo sólo el 19 por ciento de la
población se informa con medios impresos
mientras que el porcentaje era del 45
por ciento en 2017 por otro lado en
españa el interés por las noticias ha
caído 30 puntos desde 2015 del 85 al 55
por ciento en esto en méxico por ejemplo
sólo un 18% de la población cree que los
medios están a salvo de la influencia
del poder y en colombia por ejemplo el
40 por ciento de la población usa
whatsapp para informarse y un 34 por
ciento youtube y por otro lado pues en
temas no que aparecen en las noticias
este informe hace hincapié en la guerra
en ucrania por ejemplo y señala que la
mayoría de usuarios de consumidores de
las noticias pues da mucha importancia a
la información de contexto para lograr
entender esta guerra más allá de las
noticias sobre el avance del conflicto
que van saliendo pues en el día a día
rosa le pregunto qué hay del interés
sobre las noticias relacionadas con el
cambio climático pues hemos querido
seleccionar algunos de los gráficos que
aparecen en este informe para pues
ayudar a transmitir mejor estas
conclusiones por un lado hay un desglose
por regiones y por países y vemos que en
américa latina donde más interesa la
información sobre cambio climático es en
chile un país que se encuentra a 10
puntos por delante del país al que le
interesa menos que sería digamos perú en
asia-pacífico donde hay un mayor interés
es en filipinas y un menor interés en
australia o también en hong kong en
áfrica así que hay que comentar que este
estudio sólo estudia tres países
sudáfrica kenia y nigeria y todos están
más o menos pues a la par en el tema del
interés por las noticias sobre el cambio
climático donde este interés es
mayoritario en el sur de europa pues
vemos que en grecia donde hay un mayor
interés y en españa en el que menos y
así podemos ir viendo pues en las
distintas regiones pero es pues muy
resaltable que este informe también nos
da las razones
del interés no por el cambio climático
vemos pues una comparativa entre digamos
el posicionamiento político que en el
que se declaran las personas que han
sido pues entrevista de sprays de
informe y su interés por el cambio
climático vemos en este gráfico en azul
es este azul verde a las personas que se
declaran de izquierda en el naranja las
que se declaran de centro y en violetas
que se declaran de derecha y vemos que
hay mucha diferencia por ejemplo en
países como chile o puedes eeuu dónde a
la izquierda se declara mucho más
interesada por las noticias relacionadas
con el cambio climático que no la
derecha y también hay una cuestión por
edad y es que los más jóvenes las
personas que tienen entre 18 y 24 años
consideran que los medios de
comunicación tienen que asumir una
postura clara a la hora de dar
información sobre el cambio climático y
pues defender la lucha y la acción
climática y no mantenerse neutrales pero
vamos a ver ahora las tendencias de
acceso a la información en función de
las plataformas y los dispositivos
utilizados para consumir la información
si vayamos el siguiente gráfico en que
pues estudia la evolución del acceso a
la información como bien decías a través
de los distintos dispositivos en eeuu
entre 2013 y 2022 vemos en azul clarito
el uso de la televisión que decae vemos
en naranja la prensa en papel que
también decae y en rojo la radio que
también decae ligeramente se mantiene
bastante estable la información online
que también pues incluye la de las redes
sociales en violeta y
oscuro respectivamente y entre los
jóvenes esto no está en este gráfico
sino en otros pero que no tenemos el
tiempo de mostrar pues es cada vez más
popular el uso de redes sociales como
instagram y tick tock pues para acceder
a las noticias y vemos que twitter
decayó ligeramente tras un pico en su
uso a raíz de la pandemia de covite 19
también vemos que las redes sociales ya
tienen un pico en 2017 que este gráfico
asocia pues con el mandato de donald
trump y vemos raúl esto es pues muy
interesante que decae a nivel global el
número de personas que dicen estar muy o
extremadamente
interesadas en las noticias esto pues es
una caída muy marcada como vemos en el
siguiente gráfico en argentina en brasil
o en españa mientras que es una
tendencia más estable en alemania suecia
suiza países bajos o finlandia pues rosa
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de verdad que se nos queda
por fuera muchísima información de este
extenso estudio pero que les invitamos a
ver dónde puede encontrarlos a la gente
pues la gente puede encontrarla en
routers e institu si buscan este estudio
anual sobre el consumo de noticias y
recordar que cada país estudiado tiene
su propio perfil en el que pueden
encontrar pues un análisis del panorama
mediático de en manos de quienes están
los medios de comunicación de la
libertad de prensa de la libertad de
información el derecho a la información
y también pues en casos como méxico lo
peligroso que es también informar de
forma crítica reversa gracias entonces
por toda la información nos vemos mañana
con más de revista de prensa pasamos a
china a salvar en este corresponsal